c'est bien comme ça oh c'est l'alcool
c'est l'alcool
j'ai eu peur de ce doigt qu'on va les
passer en bas de repris en crochet basse
on doit le du crochet et kévin lellouche
oui elle est très sympathique kamiel et
en commun mais elle peut être vénèrent
des fois en général seraient enfin
de faire les marseillais saison l'écurie
à mykonos je sais moi pour de vrai
magelis dit je vais rater le fait alors
j'essaie je tiens régale avec le bouffon
du lol dans la tête vénère mais les
cheveux sont énervés aussi c'est sérieux
qui mêle oui j'ai joué à la juventus
non j'ai cru mais pas moi je ne sais pas
moi c'est pas moi c'est la fouine ça se
voit et était remplaçant ça se voit mais
clara morgane on a cherché john wall et
tout ça mais elle est toujours fraîche
sur les photos je trie beaucoup encore
montré des photos et il en dit vous
n'avez pas toujours août cette coiffure
mais déjà les nains c'était blondin oui
mais voilà une coupe un peu jacquouille
la fripouille possible
[Applaudissements]
à
beaucoup